- What we're going to do
in this video is talk about
the incumbent advantage.
And, this is the idea
that the person who is
already in power, the incumbent,
has an advantage in elections.
And, in particular,
we're going to focus on
Presidential elections,
although this idea is pretty
common across different offices.
Now, it turns out that if
you go back over, roughly,
the last 100 years, in
Presidential elections that had
and incumbent, that had a
sitting President running
for a second term or maybe
a third, or a forth term
in the case of FDR, you have
more than 80% of the time,
it goes to the incumbent.
And this right over
here is a picture of the
Presidential Debates from
C-SPAN and this in 2012
between President Barack
Obama and Mitt Romney.
And President Obama, of
course, was the incumbent
and he went on to win.
And, once again, not unusual,
this happened 80% of the time.
The last time that a challenger
was able to unseat an
incumbent was in 1992 when
you have President Clinton was
able to beat President George H. W. Bush,
George W. Bush's father.
George H. W. Bush and the time before ...
and this is 26 years ago,
26 years before the time
of the making of this video.
And, to go even before that,
the last time before 1992
would have been 1980, when
Reagan is able to beat Carter.
So, this is a very unusual
thing for a challenger
to be able to beat an incumbent.
Now one thing that I would like you to do
is pause this video.
Think about why incumbents
might have such an advantage.
Okay, so there's many
scholarly papers written about
the idea of the incumbent
advantage, both at the
Presidential level and at other levels.
But we can come up with
some ideas as to why
the incumbent has the advantage.
One is people already imagine
that individual as President
because they are the President.
On top of that, because
they are already President,
they've had many years of being
in the national spotlight.
And even during the
Presidential campaign, they are
still the President and so
they have that bully pulpit
that President Roosevelt,
Theodore Roosevelt talked about.
Bully pulpit, where they
can get people's attention
when they want to.
Even though the challenger
might be well-funded, and
the press is definitely
going to pay attention to the
challenger and give them a lot of voice.
Because the President is
the President, they have the
State of the Union Address,
they can call Special Sessions
of Congress, they have
regular press briefings,
and so they have a much
larger voice even compared to
a very prominent challenger.
On top of that, there might
be some notion of experience
and this idea of experience
can go in many directions.
No matter which candidate
has more life experience,
which one is older, one could
argue that no one has ever
really ever been the President
unless they are the President.
And, so someone who has been
in that job for four years
has been able to build
some experiences that maybe
they'll be able to build
on for their second term.
While, the other person might have to,
no matter what they've done
in the rest of their life,
being the President is
fairly new experience.
The other idea is that they
are experienced campaigners.
That they have already run
a successful Presidential
campaign and this is
their second time around,
which could help in winning that campaign.
Another idea that might
help an incumbent...
and once again, this is
me thinking about it,
I encourage you to think
about it and see if you
buy these or could come up with others...
is maybe there is a sense of patriotism.
That people are used to
thinking of the incumbent as
their President for the last several years
and so they feel some
sense of loyalty to them.
This could even be
supercharged if maybe it's in
wartime or if the country
is facing some type of
foreign policy crisis that
they want to stand behind
the person during that time of crisis.
They don't want to change
who is in charge in
the middle of a war or
something like that.
So, I will leave you there.
These are just some ideas
why we see this phenomenon
of an incumbent advantage.
I encourage you to think
about why this is happening.